[Music]
we are around 1550 i don't remember our
exact grading let's play a ten minute
game okay
e4
okay that's it that is the game-winning
move
aha e5 all right
been a while actually since we faced e45
we are still playing
fortnite scotch as
you folks
know okay bishop c5 this is actually
quite important that we face this move
because
the response to this move
is perhaps not intuitive
i think some of you might be inclined to
develop our bishop but that simply
transposes to the four knights without
d4 and it's too good to be true if if
this move existed everybody would play
it because it prevents d4
on but fortunately for us this move has
a flaw
and it's the fork trick knight takes e5
which by now should be familiar to all
of you now in some positions it's good
in other positions it's not as good in
this position it is quite good
because
okay bishop takes f2
classic mistake
of of this level
and this is the reason why most people
don't end up taking on e5 if they're
seeing this position for the first time
because this looks very scary
right black gives up the bishop for the
pawn so material is going to be equal
because we took a pawn on e5
and it appears that our king is out in
the open and
for the rest of the game and there's
nothing we can do about it and things
are bad
but this is a complete illusion because
first of all
depriving us of castling rights black
has also made a major concession
they've given up a million tempi that we
can now use to grab control of the
center the other thing black has
given up is the dark squared bishop
which can be quite important in such
positions so we start by playing d4 we
start by controlling the center and we
notice that none of these checks are
even remotely scary our king can always
hide on g1 there we go
our king can and will hide on g1
doesn't make as much sense to go toward
the center
now you might say well what about the
rook isn't aren't we concerned about the
rook being locked in we'll deal with
that right we don't we don't need to
worry about that yet it's not like we
have to use our rook in the next couple
of moves one way or another we'll figure
it out
and one way of doing that is to go h3
king h2 and then moving the bishop out
one way or another will eventually get
our rook back into civilization
okay knight g6 not a bad move
not a bad move and we haven't we have
choices here there's multiple moves
they're all
good um we can take this sort of more
quiet developmental approach
and just go like bishop e3 and queen d2
and these types of moves we can take the
more ambitious central approach and go
e5 and try to blow him off the board
a lot of you i'm sure are tempted by the
move knight t5 but i
i'm a little bit cold toward that move
the reason why is that it sends the
queen back to d8 where it wants to go
anyway
and after that i can chase the knight
away with c6
so both sides end up losing a tempo
knight t5 isn't anything special so i
much prefer
to play a normal developing move such as
bishop e3 when in doubt
you transition back to moves that you
know are good right you're not sure what
to do okay can i develop my pieces
all right now we can develop our other
bishop to d3 the only slightly annoying
thing that
i wanted to prevent by playing queen d2
is is knight f4
bishop d3 knight f4 is
ever so slightly annoying you know what
i'm saying so
let's begin by getting our queen to d2
and building a little battery and who
knows maybe maybe
we will want to play bishop g5 at some
point so this move has other benefits
all right
where should we develop this bishop to
and there is no i no there is a right
answer in fact
yeah there is a right answer
i believe
there's two decent squares
the two decent squares are d3 and c4 but
we want to play more ambitiously we have
a development advantage
you want to err on the side of you know
developing more aggressively so we play
bishop c4 in addition i have a feeling
that he might go d6 and that loses a
queen
all right ladies and gentlemen you do
the rest
i should do like a profit compilation
now there is one
one more pitfall to avoid it's not rook
f1
which allows queen h4 it is bishop g5
i've shown this trick before bishop
comes to g5
queen is literally trapped and it's
precisely because where bishop on c4 is
guarding the only escape square
there we go
this is how you play tricky moves you
play moves that are good
in and of themselves but if they also
contain a trick then you should
definitely play them
yeah this is over i mean it's a full
queen for a piece there black can't even
get two pieces it's just one minor for a
queen okay
let's try to make short work of the
conversion
um
again i want to repeat this many times
don't stress too much about my moves in
this stage of the game
there isn't just one way to convert an
extra queen there's a million right and
really anything within reason is fine
we can take on e7 here if we want we can
trade i don't want to i like my bishop i
don't see a need to trade further the
one thing i always say is you shouldn't
go out of your way to trade more pieces
right you don't need to simplify to win
the game so simplify if it's convenient
don't simplify if it's not convenient
and don't give up your nicest pieces
well same with d5 bishop d7 and we've
given up an outpost on e5 i like h4 yeah
let's go h4 because this is this does
two things at once it threatens h5 which
wins another piece
and it you know you find a job for the
rook
now it's important to ask the sam if
you're mikhail tall you're probably
taking on h6 i'm sure that's crushing
um
but we can do something similar but in a
slightly less outlandish way
actually you know we can take on h6 here
i mean what is there to lose
yeah let's just take a niche i mean this
is so winning gh queen takes h6 and then
h5 is coming this is barely even a
sacrifice we're gonna win back one of
the pieces i mean i mean you shouldn't
even be surprised at this we're going to
go h5
the knight will have to drop back to h8
and then we have for starters we have
queen g5 check which picks up the other
knight
you see that
it's over
and this is a purely intuitive sacrifice
they didn't calculate a single variation
not a single one
should we still play h5
did f5 change what we do
we absolutely should go h5 and don't say
no just because i asked we absolutely
should now if the knight moves the
bishop on e6 is undefended did you
notice that when he played f5 the bishop
on e6 was left undefended i tell you to
do that that's very important
anytime a pawn is moved are there any
pieces which are now undefended you have
to keep updating your perception of the
board
okay let's get our rook into the game
our our
other rook and then we can lift our
hrook if we want
okay now the simplest is e takes f5 if
knight takes f5 we can play rook takes
and the rook is uncapturable due to the
pin
this f pawn is going to say this is
completely resignable
yeah i like to ask questions whose
answer is yes i think like teachers do
this too often where if they ask a
question of that format like should we
do this or should we do that the answer
is always no but
with me you never know like the answer
might be
yes um
okay
well we can win more pieces with f6 we
can play h6
you know the hiller okay let's go six
the hilarious thing is we might have to
give her
well let's cross that bridge and get
there
so
a little nitpicky guys but what should
we do queen takes c7 or rook takes f6
what is like technically the more
accurate move if you calculate
take the rook first because if you take
the knight he goes rook eight f7
and we'll have to give our queen up
because dirk on f1 is hanging
yeah we take the rook
and then queen takes knight and i don't
know why this guy isn't resigned
or go
boom
let's go h6 strike from the other side
if rook h6 we take the rook and we win
the knight
okay
i take c4 yes i'm playing fast but this
is also very elementary
well
maybe this guy should be playing for
stalemate because
apparently i'm not very good at
detecting them today
not your resign now
you disconnected okay fair enough
very simple game but
i want everybody to remember that this
bishop takes f2 hopefully i was able to
explain why this is not dangerous for
white
so
as you climb from 1500 to 1600 one of
the things you need to stop taking for
granted
is
you know
is the is king safe you need to learn
how to better evaluate king safety and
what that often means is in certain
situations you got to be able to press
the button and keep the king in the
center sometimes you don't want to
castle at all
sometimes
you have to determine that it's okay for
the king to be on e2 or f7
right if you're below that rating it's
okay to sort of use shorthand if the
king is in the center it's unsafe if the
king is open it's unsafe if the king is
castled it's relatively safe
but as you get toward intermediate level
you need to start being more specific in
my opinion
i don't know if that makes sense but
just one of the items that you should be
thinking and more actively about
okay finally
yeah not much to discuss
here i mean i kind of talked about
everything during the game but uh
yeah bishop c5
is is a move but it's not great because
of this knight takes e5 idea
okay bishop c5 knight takes e5 i'm not
reporting it i wouldn't recommend that
you report people i mean choose your
battles you know
so
who can tell me what is the traditional
way that you are taught to meet this
situation
there is a move that if you read chess
books and stuff they tell you that this
is how you should play bishop d6 yeah
and the reason is that you should keep
your bishop and generally that's right
you should play bishop d6 in such
positions because giving up your bishop
so early is bad
and in fact it's one of the only ways to
win back the pawn if you play bishop
takes d4
then you've gotten yourself into even
greater trouble because look at this
x-ray d6 f4
so bishop d6 is indeed
how you should proceed
and black is slightly worse in this
position
because white has better control of the
center
let me just open the game again sorry so
i can analyze
why does better control of the center
white has the possibility of going f4
um in opening explorer i see that f4 is
a move bishop d3 is a move
obviously you're not afraid of bishop
take c3 check
as i've said many times
queen side pawn structure is not as
important when you castle kingside the
two bishops are important the fact that
white has a huge lead in development is
important
so you can analyze this a bit on your
own if you want but i it looks like
either f4 bishop d3 give an advantage
sorry
but nonetheless this is incomparably
better than what our opponent did
because after d4 it's already terrible
queen f6 we just tuck our king away
and now i think tons of people just go
knight d5 straight away
and did i properly explain why i'm not
as in love with knight d5 as it might
as as you might be you know
because it's almost like you're running
out ahead of the other soldiers
but the night alone isn't gonna cause
trouble and the other thing to remember
is that just because the queen is
more advanced than it is on the initial
score doesn't mean the queen is well
placed the queen has lost him the game i
already realized that using the queen
and keeping it on f6
can be
incredibly powerful we only attack the
queen when we need to the threat is
stronger than its execution
it's almost like you hear the first two
letters two numbers of your lottery
ticket
they match and you cash in the five
dollar prize rather than hearing all
eight number lottery tickets
right cash in the queen
when it's worth it not immediately
bishop b3 knight e7 and that's exactly
what we did bishop c4 now black can
refrain from d6 but the position's
terrible we go rook f1 h4 h5 i mean
there isn't even much to discuss here
this is just terrible
everything makes sense any questions
but mainly just remember knight takes c5
okay looks like everything is clear
everything makes sense excellent that's
what i like to hear
[Music]